mit dem rücktritt von anne spiegel als
familienministerin ist die debatte um
die frauenquote jahr wieder voll in gang
gekommen und ich muss zugeben dass eine
spiegel frauen in der politik und in
führungspositionen einen echten
bärendienst erwiesen hat indem sie
nämlich gezeigt hat wie es nicht geht
wie man kind und karriere nicht unter
einen hut bekommt das ist schade
das hat sie einfach maximal tragisch
gezeigt sie war total überlastet das
hätte einem mann übrigens auch passieren
können aber der eindruck ist nun mal
hängen geblieben eine frau mit kindern
hat es nicht gepackt und das ist
schlecht für alle frau mit kindern und
ich behaupte diese ganze misere wäre
nicht passiert wenn wir an statt einer
frauenquote eine familien quote hätten
dann hätte zum beispiel nur ein beispiel
anton hofreiter familienminister werden
können der hat nämlich einen sohn und
auch männer können sich ja um
gleichberechtigung und familienpolitik
kümmern jetzt ist es lisa paus die wird
sich als alleinerziehende natürlich auch
sehr gut kümmern aber diesen ganzen
umweg über an der spiegel hätten wir uns
glaube ich sparen können wenn also schon
eine quote dann bitte eine familien
quote denn dann würde sich auch endlich
der kern des dilemmas vielleicht einmal
auflösen denn die quote ist ja nur ein
ausdruck des problems nämlich der nicht
vereinbarkeit von beruf und familie
elternschaft hat ja eher karriere tod
bringt es leider oftmals mit sich oder
zumindest karriereknick und ich kann
jahre chancen weil wir einfach viel zu
unflexibel
hier sind als braucht also nicht
zwingend mehr frauen sondern vor allem
mehr väter und mütter an der spitze des
staates und den unternehmen familien
sicherung des meiner ansicht nach gleich
zukunftssicherung und dieses motto
sollte eigentlich auch in jedem in jenen
also sollte ein dreh und angelpunkt in
jedem unternehmen werden also wir müssen
eigentlich dahin kommen dass diese
menschenverachtende frage kind oder
karriere dass die obsolet wird und um
diese frage kümmern sich auch wenn sich
das jetzt hart anhört frauen ohne kinder
kümmern sich um diese frage
wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr aber eltern
werden es tun denn die erleben dieses
problem ja einfach jeden tag und ich
denke dass sich menschen die betroffen
sind immer mehr einsetzen werden als
solche die es vielleicht nicht direkt
sind und ich höre schon ja
ja keine kinder also ich wäre auf jeden
fall eine verdammt schlimme ministerin
ich das gar nicht werden aber lena du
hast ja eine tochter ich glaube fünf
jahre alt ist deine naja du könntest
also laut ich könnte ihn alle drei
werden beim ministerium werden was sie
denn von einer familienkutsche er finde
ich wahnsinnig spannend das thema und
ich ziehe unglaublich meinen hut vor dir
wollen weil wir haben ja gerade wechsel
schon so ein bisschen darüber gesprochen
wie du das hättest du hast zwei kinder
fünf und sieben jahre als sind sie und
bis hin zu den fünf und zehn jahre alt
also schon ein halber teenager das macht
sich gerade einfacher und wir bringen
die halbe woche hier legt eine rasant
schnelle imposante karriere hin während
dein mann zu hause eingespannt wird und
er macht das mit erfolg wir haben gerade
darüber gesprochen dass man quasi von
haus aus ja immer erst mal davon ausgeht
die mama macht das alles der papa wird
sogar gelobt wenn er einmal im büro zu
einem meeting künstlich kommt wenn das
baby gerade ein bisschen fieber wir
mütter wir werden gar nicht gefragt wir
wir haben keine möglichkeit ich du wir
alle wir haben keine möglichkeit wir
müssen pünktlich zur arbeit erscheint
ein federndes kind ist keine ausrede
also meinem job sie würden mit den vogel
zeigen während ein mann da quasi noch
eine kleine runde applaus bekommt wenn
es dann trotzdem scharf ist für die
familien quote alena
wie sie in der realität aussehen könnte
okay ich habe man müsste sie einfach um
ändern dann hätten auch väter die chance
also ich aber ohne kinder patricia was
hat sich da frage ich bin reden geht im
quote weil eine quote kommt lassen sich
auch komplexe behandlung gleich weil ich
eine frau bin deswegen habe ich da ein
bonus dass ich finde die quote überhaupt
ein totaler unsinn und ich finde man
muss das ganz anders angehen wir müssen
uns fragen wie arbeitet man in der
politik das ist doch die frage es geht
doch nicht darum ob jetzt eine verstehen
oder ein verstehe weil mit kind gesegnet
an der spitze steht es geht darum dass
die politik einfach unmenschliche
arbeitsbedingungen teilweise hat weil
natürlich fielen also der mann dominiert
ja noch die politik und der hat endlos
zeit für endlose sitzungen und ich finde
es geht um es geht darum dass man sagt
wie können wir wie können wir die
termine kürzen wie können wir
aussprachen kürzen und wie schützen wir
menschen die nicht nur kinder haben
sondern vielleicht auch einen
pflegebedürftigen angehörigen oder
vielleicht ein pferd oder ich weiß nicht
was ich immer ist ganz egal warum alle
menschen haben irgendwelche daten die
meisten menschen die ich kenne haben
irgendeine verantwortung
es gibt auch aber eigentlich ist das
nicht das gleiche nein natürlich nicht
das war ein scherz muss ich sofort
zurücknehmen aber es gibt viele menschen
ehrenamtlich sich zum beispiel auch in
der politik ehrenamtlich um andere
menschen kümmern und in dem fall muss
die politik einfach die arbeitsweise
muss so gestaltet werden dass es nicht
24 stunden job ist sondern habe genau um
das würden sich doch eltern viel eher
kümmern und so weiß ich nicht mehr dafür
eingesetzt dass wir sehen das problem
einfach jeden teil hinein ist
entschuldige dass das problem geht doch
nicht nur familien an sondern auch jeden
menschen also jede person hat auch ins
privatleben und dieses privatleben
braucht man auch in der politik um
anregungen zu bekommen um andere
meinungen kennenzulernen um nicht nur in
dieser blase in dieser politik blase zu
leben und deswegen finde ich also die
empfehlung dass das nur noch familie
familie zählt bei der berufung in ein
höheres politisches amt nun auch das
habe ich das sah ja wenn wir schon eine
quote haben hab ich gesagt dann wäre
besser eine familien der heute als eine
frauen die frau die vom spiegel habe es
dann uns frauen echt ein ei gelegt
weil sie auch so weinerlich war und sie
hat den mann noch die schuld gegeben und
ja also ich meinen millionen millionen
deutsche mütter und väter haben in der
pandemie ihre kinder in irgendeiner form
sie durchbringen müssen sie unterhalten
und betreuen und die haben das auch alle
geschah muss oder mate kurz unterbrechen
auch wenn didi und hasi
lebens nun mit der zeit und wir wollen
hier nach frau groos meinung hören ob
sie denn für die familien quote ist also
erst mal würde ich sagen diese
diskussion hat eine ganz starke
generellen und dynamik ja wir sind beide
ich darf das sagen über 50 jahre und
jüngere frauen reagieren da ich habe
zwei kinder als alleinerziehende mutter
in den 90er jahren in der republik
großgezogen also das war die arschkarte
nummer um es mal ganz so sagen ja das
war noch eine zeit wo man rabenmutter so
auf dem gesicht einige städte und keine
kita kann
ich hab's gelöst mit 250 prozent einsatz
ja also punkte gibt da habe ich auch
keine andere lösung wenn man muss dann
macht man mal was soll man schon machen
ja aber wie du das eben gesagt hast ja
das fieber beginnt war kein argument
nicht wirklich im job zu sein ja ich
möchte dass keine wünschen was er denn
nicht verändert und das sollte sich auch
acer hat sich verändert wenn ich das
beurteilen kann was heute ja dass zum
beispiel eine universitäten frauenquote
gender gerecht und so weiter es hat sich
ganz viel geändert ich war
frauenbeauftragte an der universität in
österreich wo ich war inzwischen dass an
den universitäten sogar schon so dass
man zwischen im akademischen und dem
biologischen alter unterscheidet das
heißt wenn ein kind kriegt man an
rechnungs punkte und so weiter zettel
waren sind das an und bat ihn aber
beiseite was ihnen was ich sagen würde
ist wir müssen es trotzdem auflösen es
geht nicht nur um die politik es geht
auch um die finanzen finanzmärkte es
geht um gehe da wo macht und geld ist ja
also es geht im prinzip und vorstände um
die große unternehmen natürlich sind die
frauen überall ja die hilfskräfte die
pflegekräfte die krankenschwestern die
schlecht bezahlten jobs wie auch immer
um diese frauen kümmert sich ja keiner
aber es geht da wo es sozusagen immer
nicht passt oder klatschten wir am
beispiel von frau spiegel ist da wo man
eine erhebliche verantwortung hat
meistens viel verdient meistens viel
prestige hat ja und da ist diese
frauengeschichte dann so richtig frauen
in die vorstände frauen in den
finanzmarkt was auch immer das auch in
den universitäten sind werden längst
noch nicht bei zehn prozent ja und da
ist ein generelles problem da bin ich
dabei dieses problem ist wir lösen ob
wir das nur mit einer quote oder mit
einer familienkutsche lösen im zweifel
zwar geschenkt wir müssen es lösen aber
es ist ein breiteres problem und das hat
ganz viel da bin ich bei ihnen damit zu
tun wie wir über den grip den begriff
der arbeit verstehen was ist arbeit ja
macht man die heute zu hause oder nicht
jetzt auch nach der pandemie ist ja noch
mal anders wie lösen wir das auf wie man
es gibt ja vorschläge ohne ende 32
stunden woche für frauen elterngeld was
auch immer ich glaube es ist viel
passiert es muss noch mehr passieren
aber es ist nicht nur die politik und am
ende glaube ich sind auch individuen las
man auch gucken annalena baerbock auch
zwei kleine mädchen ja reißt im moment
irgendwie munter durch die
weltgeschichte da ist jetzt auch noch
problem aufgetreten und das ist toll ich
verteile dafür genau was ich nur sagen
will am ende ist es tatsächlich auch
hängt es auch von jeder frau ab ja also
das kann man glaube ich auch irgendwo
nicht so ganz generalisieren ich kenne
frauen die sie mit einem kind
überfordert ich kenne frauen die am fünf
kinder und arbeitet nebenbei voll beruf
will ich noch nicht da
generali sie aber ist ja irgendwo ja das
finde ich aber ein ganz schönes
schlusswort zu dem thema weil das ist
eigentlich das was der richtige ist
jeder muss für sich selbst entscheiden
ob man berufstätig sein wie oft man
nicht ob man kinder haben würden jeder
soll es machen wie er möchte